oh the promo the state of michigan has
some of the most dangerous cities
americans have great state is beautiful
but there's some very dangerous places
detroit is the most famous obviously but
it's not the only one
muskegon heights kalamazoo jackson
ypsilanti
all have crime rates far higher than the
national average as do other michigan
cities
in detroit violence escalated to new and
terrifying levels over the last year
more than a thousand people were shot in
detroit in the past 12 months
so dana nessel is the attorney general
of michigan as the
state's chief law enforcement officer
you think she would be very concerned
about all those people getting murdered
in her state but she's not concerned
nor is nestle bothered to investigate
her governor gretchen whitmer who like
andrew cuomo is responsible for the
deaths of so many nursing home residents
from
covit gretchen whitmer is dana nessl's
political ally so she's getting a pass
completely
data nestle has better things to do than
stop murders or figure out why elderly
people are dying
she has instead marshaled the full force
of the state to crush a single
disobedient restaurant owner
a polish immigrant called marlena pavlos
hackney whom we've had on the show
pavlos hackney's crime was disobeying
state corona regulations so last week
nessel had her handcuffed
and arrested in a sting operation she
drove to work
keep in mind that there is no proof that
pavlos hackney is responsible for a
single covet infection not one no proof
but dana nessl sent her to jail anyway
and then issued a highly self-righteous
press release bragging that she did it
pablo's hacking was released from jail
yesterday but only because officials
determined that her highly dangerous
restaurant had been completely closed
down
it's hard to imagine a more
disproportionate response than this but
for those who've watched dana nessel for
the past two years is not surprising
dana nestle is out of control she's an
ideologue she cares only about partisan
advantage she should be impeached
by the michigan legislature for her many
abuses of power she's that corrupt
but she's also a bit of a dim bulb not a
super genius and that's why when she was
asked why she put marlena pavlos hackney
in jail
nestle actually admitted the real reason
she didn't make up some fake legal
principles she said straightforwardly
that marlena pavlos hackney had dared to
come on this show at 8pm
and complain about her that's no longer
allowed
and to compound the offense pablo
hackney tried to raise money for her own
legal defense
and that too is now a crime in dana
nessl's michigan
sound like america to you oh no it
doesn't it sounds like dictatorship
didn't nestle is a threat to the rule of
law the law that she is charged with
enforcing and she should be removed
immediately when people like this
take positions like attorney general
it's not a joke
well